Andy asked me if he could take a minute
to talk to our viewers directly I don't
know why don't you wanted to do that did
you wanna do that now Andy yeah I might
as well get it over with all right I
don't know if this is but go ahead go
ahead
okay hi America in the next couple of
days you're gonna be reading some stuff
about me that is not good in fact it's
really bad I just want to remind you
that there is two sides to every story
and I need to tell my side right now
because once TMZ comes out with that
video my lawyers are gonna tell me to
shut up and not talk to anyone okay Andy
this is kind of worrying me what is it
you did what did you do not meet Conan
my disease okay
find your disease your disease what was
it something sexual but only it was Andy
was it something violent if only it was
violent and it wasn't violent and it
wasn't sexual Conan but if convicted I'm
going to prison for the rest of my life
Eddie what is it you did what did you do
you see this this is a CPAP mask most
people use it at night to stop snoring
but you can modify these with just a
tube of superglue a cup of alcohol bait
mixed with baking soda and a funnel
duct-taped to a garden hose it's called
a Bonnie rig in the community what
community
Andy what did you do anyway if you take
a bonny rig into a 7-eleven when you're
half out of your mind on psychoactive
mushrooms and you like the business end
of it with a creme brulee 20 Andy stop
what is it Tony you're clear and clear
yes they found all the hair and the
title sticks they're in there too what
about Gina she never left Hong Kong what
the hell are you two talking about Andy
what in God's name did you do Andy
apparently nothing at all
[Applause]
you